think everyone's too transactional like  tonight I don't sit here and say this  fourteen thousand dollar meal because a  bunch of wine a bunch of people I'm like  what did we get out of that did we get  77 000 for that 14k We're not gonna get  [ __ ] out of it today but we might also  get a six million dollar client from it  in three years because of tonight I just  think that too many people are  transactional what's in it for me right  now very quickly and for me back to the  marathon versus the Sprint this is like  how do I bring as much value to as many  people here as humanly possible by  educating them by trying to match them  together no referral fee no [ __ ]  credit no nothing and I don't give a  [ __ ] I'm not living [ __ ] life for  credit or for [ __ ] money I'm living  it for like [ __ ] putting goodness  into the world I know how to get mine  the more you do good you'll get yours in  the pockets if you [ __ ] focus on your  heart